Rund um die erde sind etwa 500 mini satelliten unterwegs und verfolgen die signale von flugzeugen schiffen und warenströmen machen
wettervorhersagen besser und entdecken überschwemmungen
waldbrände und so weiter in echtzeit genau wie die konsequenzen des klimawandels
bald sollen sie auch die entlegensten regionen der welt mit dem globalen computer netzwerk verbinden in den nächsten zehn jahren könnten es rund
6000 satelliten werden aber auch
nachrichtendienste und das militär
springe ich jetzt darauf an warum genau diese branche so explodiert was die mini satelliten alles können und welche risiken sich hinter diesen
wert beobachtungen verbergen das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt bei klicks zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Am ende des videos habe ich noch ein bussi für euch ein gratis exemplar der zeitschrift technology review
sehr cool in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion ist dieses video entstanden
ja etwa 500 kilometer hoch fliegen die mini satelliten und zwar jeden tag exakt zur selben uhrzeit über denselben punkt der erdoberfläche
ihre kameras machen dabei ununterbrochen bilder allein 88 der insgesamt 104 satelliten die im letzten jahr vom indischen
raumfahrtzentrum ins all gebracht wurden stammen von dem kalifornischen unternehmen
planet ihre mini
satelliten nennen sie darf es also tauben diese sind gut vier kilogramm schwer und so groß wie drei clubs setzen diese zahl
100 vier satelliten auf einen streich ist tatsächlich weltrekord und zeigt wie krass diese branche explodiert planet verspricht seinen kunden
eine tagesaktuelle
abdeckung der erdland massen aber sie sind nicht allein da oben mehr als 500 mini satelliten kümmern sich um wettervorhersagen oder
die transponder signale von flugzeugen und schiffen aber auch waldbrände und überschwemmungen werden in echtzeit angezeigt
ein kanadisches start up hat eine software entwickelt die auf den satellitenbildern
basiert und der regierung alle waldbrände mit teil zu dem auch eine prognose wie sich diese weiter
ausbreiten werden in zukunft
sollen die bilder dann milliarden von sensoren und schlauer geräte in entlegenen regionen der welt mit dem globalen computer netzwerk verbinden als teil
des internets der dinge vorbei sind die zeiten in denen sich nur wenige firmen satelliten leisten konnten doch damals
waren die
noch lange nicht so mini sondern eher so groß wie ein reisebus und das machte ihren bau und ihrem start so aufwendig ganz anders
sieht das bei den kleinen satelliten aus die direkt in rauen mengen
ja durch nur eine rakete ins all gebracht werden dazu kommen neue technische lösungen die das alles möglich machen durch künstliche
intelligenz können die unmengen an daten überhaupt erst ausgewertet werden auch solarzellen
leistungsfähige batterien
hochauflösende mini kameras und geschrumpfte schaltkreise machen den erfolg überhaupt erst möglich
wie an einer perlenkette aufgereiht ziehen die kaufen ihre bahnen im sogenannten sonnen synchronen orbit linie für linie
entsteht so tag für tag ein bild der
kompletten land masse des planeten und das mit einer auflösung von drei bis fünf metern es gibt aber auch noch
hochgenaue satelliten mit 70 zentimeter auf lösungen
auch eine neue denkweise hat dazu geführt den fachkreisen auch als das angel
aerospace genannt also so etwas wie die agile luft und raumfahrt hier zeigt man mut zum scheitern
weder zeit noch geld werden verpulvert um jede einzelne kleine schrauben für den einsatz im weltraum fit zu machen
stattdessen zeigen die unternehmen mut zur lücke und nehmen start und fälle gerne in kauf 2014
beispielsweise explodierte eine amerikanische und ares rakete und
26 satelliten von planet waren auf einmal verloren den ausbau der flotte
verzögerte das aber nur um wenige monate das alles also der einfache aufbau und der geringe preis bedeutet natürlich auch abstriche
gemacht werden müssen die satelliten hat meist nicht länger als vier jahre die strategie möglichst viele
einzusetzen macht den ausfall dann aber wieder wett denn dann übernimmt eben ein anderer satellit zudem haben die unternehmen so die möglichkeit die
hardware immer weiter zu entwickeln gefeilt werden soll demnächst beispielsweise noch an der
datenübertragung und den aufgenommenen wellenlängen angedacht sind auch
triebwerke mit denen die mini satelliten in zukunft aufgerüstet werden könnten der markt wird auf mehr als 30 milliarden dollar geschätzt
denn in den nächsten zehn jahren wird mit insgesamt
6200 kleinen satelliten im all
rechnet doch dazu müssen noch einige faktoren optimiert werden per anhalter ins all zu kommen ist von der logistik her sehr aufwendig die
termine sind rar und die umlaufbahn der großen satelliten
entsprechen nicht den bahnen der club setzt die zukunft könnte in mini raketen liegen also
sowie die elektro von roccat lab ohne viel schnickschnack dafür eine elektrisch betriebene turbo pumpe aus dem 3d drucker
49.000 dollar pro kilogramm nutzlast ist hier der preis insgesamt kann die rakete 150 kilogramm
transportieren der transport ist zwar teurer als beispielsweise die mitfahrgelegenheit auf der verein von spacex aber dafür exklusiv
und solch ein kleines system kann durchaus häufiger statt derzeit laufen unzählige projekte die in diese richtung
gehen zudem müsste eine weitere bedingung
eingelöst werden damit der markt weiter so ausgebaut werden kann mit der zeit die bilder müssten einen deutlichen mehrwert bieten schon jetzt nutzen kunden die
mini satelliten um beispielsweise den armuts index eines landes zu bestimmen
beispielsweise indem sie die ziegel und strohdächer in ländlichen gegenden zählen auch die
abholzung der wälder wird beispielsweise in peru oder vietnam mit hilfe der bilder beobachtet und dokumentiert
und selbst die sklaverei kann somit aufgedeckt werden wie es beispielsweise einem forschungsteam aus
großbritannien gelungen ist und zwar durch das aufspüren so genannter ziegelstein gürtel
gürteln also regionen in denen sich ziegelei an ziegelei wright hier werden menschen oft als
zwangsarbeiter ausgebeutet bisher werden noch freiwillige die bilderauswahl hofft hier auf künstliche intelligenz die selbst solche region
identifizieren soll dass die blending trägt hier seinen teil bei und in den letzten jahren wurden große erfolge im bereich der automatischen
bildverarbeitung gemacht doch die lassen sich leider nicht eins zu eins auf
satellitenbilder übertragen denn dort gibt es mehr als die üblichen drei farbkanäle doch in zukunft soll es auch nicht bei standbildern
bleiben ein startup aus den usa mit dem namen
will demnächst live aufnahmen von jedem punkt der erde liefern damit ließ sich so einiges beobachten
unkontrollierte waldbrände illegale fischerei oder aber die wanderin wanderung von google an und stellt euch mal vor ihr hätte google maps mit einer
live satelliten karte ziemlich stand eine intelligente bildverarbeitung würde die datenmenge reduzieren und so zitat
veränderungen viel besser erkennen und den globalen puls der erde quasi
fortwährend messen das sagt da mehr an bord abteilungsleiter die burning beim deutschen forschungszentrum für künstliche
intelligenz
dfg in kaiserslautern zu dem geplanten
youtube aus dem all das alles ist für die einen eine mega kracher vorstellung für die anderen ist der reinste horror
datenschützer beispielsweise reagieren äußerst nervös auf solche ankündigungen denn auch wenn die beteiligten unternehmen oft ihren sozialen nutzen in den vordergrund
stellen kommt das große geld woanders her blendet beispielsweise hat einen vertrag mit
der us behörde für
geheimdienstliche aufklärung ebenso mit spionage agenturen und auch das militär
zeigt sich interessiert aber auch datenreihen für einen anderen kontext sind bereits im angebot beispielsweise
von dem kalifornischen start up little insight nämlich dazu wie gut
parkplätze von supermärkten genutzt werden oder auch zum weltweiten abbau von eisenerz diese infos zeigen sehr genau
wo die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung hingeht bei diesem konkreten beispiel eben ob ein supermarkt kurz davor ist bleibt zu gehen oder ob der laden derzeit ganz gut läuft
ja vielen dank an technology review in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser ziemlich kunstzeitschrift ist dieses video
entstanden und exklusiv für pixum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen
link klickt das lohnt sich wirklich ja und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
hobby-astronom finde totgeglaubten nasa satelliten bis dann
bleibt dran